[Music]
the codex predicts our victory victory
is with so swarm deployed
nice one dear he's a puny alder
we shall prevail we shall take that
position your swanee too far is your
Raji squag
[Music]
I serve the chapter we are put on the
enemy has few places left to run we win
here ready to strike charge
[Music]
pick your table all of the sand of
Mordecai in the morning
[Music]
make them no regret Brothers Space
Marine terminators Rey Emperor spider
the enemy goes here
[Music]
the boss knows why he's doing
[Music]
tactical squad ready to move
[Music]
your orders understood
altergott a wing I can fire usage
I serve the chapter yes brother
[Music]
oh my why those are Crossin bolt pistol
and chain sword ready to strike our
victory is a short day I Kato - ah Sh
this shall be over state offenses crumb
they fall before nowhere for him to run
just so why I likes it we shall prevail
understood
die I Kato - hush your orders - Finkley
nowhere for em to run
Josh so why I like sheet victory is
within our cross the Primark
Oh
[Music]
rod Terminator reporting for glory
[Music]
just a few more shots from me get done
and this will all be over
none
always animals
[Music]
ready to deploy the codex no mercy I'll
place
ah ah boy
make your way get your tea
I stand ready spearheading assault a
fall before us
if you say so hope
we are pushing them back a fall before
the defense's crumble brother stopping
over here
yes brother captain
forward to victory
[Music]
none shall survive
[Music]
we are them on the run we're gonna take
them on a ride your orders to victory
tourists are Nakuru I stand ready alters
firing spearheading assault where I
gonna stop boys
[Music]
we are proud to serve the chapter ever
straight up on the move you got a boss
ready to strike the wisdom of the Codex
is fair if you say so we shall prevail
they fall before the defenses brothel
brother the boss knows what he's doing
[Music]
the codex predicts our victory
lady for us
you got a boss
[Music]
we are pushing them attack get to the
enemy
[Music]
you are our diode staggered shards
standing by the wisdom of the Codex is
clear
here we go
ox ox ox we shall prevail termina should
we bring death let's jump over him
victory is within our cross the codex
predicts our victory
McKay's brothers
Wilke Rock'em IBM I'd swear tongue
[Music]
my psychic mastery is at your command
this battle shall be ours we got him now
boss
[Music]
ready to strike
[Music]
the codex predicts our victory
our junk packs bring us to battle
[Music]
[Music]